[Music]
now this is a fun little segment
actually this is good this is a good uh
so you know would you rather sure
what about just would you
sure
let's play that let's begin okay number
one would you go to space I'm in space
checkmate
[Laughter]
check would you participate in a reality
TV show
Kian and JC yeah
they had a reality show on YouTube
called reality house yeah were you on it
no but that's still going isn't it I
don't know did they do a season like
last year yeah they're well it's one of
these things where like I only knew
about it because
my fans alerted me to it and then they
invited me to go on it like Kane and JC
I went on it in 2019 like pre-pandemic
and I was like
because my team at the time shucked and
they were like this is great exposure
and I'm you know you learned throughout
the course of doing this it's like
exposure isn't
beneficial when it's from the wrong
place I see and I'm not saying that
Keenan and JC are you know whatever they
have their own little Cinematic Universe
um that's kind of different from mine
and they involve themselves with people
that I don't really involve myself with
and I went on this show and it was with
some kind of problematic people and I
got kicked off first and it was the
biggest blessing of my life so I went on
people were like like I would get
recognized on the street it's like oh my
God I saw you on Keenan JC's show like
you're so funny for the 14 seconds I was
on the show and I'm like okay thanks I
think you know it was like okay this was
exposure I don't know if it was worth it
but if I had to do that again I would
not do it again especially where I am
now I would not do that like what about
like a prime time one no no like
Survivor I'm too much of a people
pleaser I would make alliances with
everybody and then get myself kicked off
yeah why did you get kicked off day one
of we had to do this stupid [__] game
where we had to sort through a
who is that
[Music]
oh my God I don't know her
in this big sand pit of flower like
cooking flour and they were like you
have to find four pinto beans
that's it we had to run to it okay and
sip yup sift through this to find pinto
beans they're this big everyone else
find them left or right left or right
I'm taking my sweet time I'm just
playing in the sand I'm just like really
not taking it as a big thing
I sort through this I'm last me and
Fouseytube oh wow okay
me and my best friend yeah yeah you guys
have a lot in common we do we actually
grew up in the same town and you know we
look a little alike as well so uh we for
the first to get kicked off because we
didn't find these [__] beans and then
they sent us home covered in flour they
were like do your ex interview and yeah
they're getting the [__] car and they
drove us three and a half hours away
from LA and we couldn't use our phones
and then they drove us all the way back
like I had packed a bag we didn't even
get to go in the house they literally
said [__] you and put me back in the car
wow it was wild they drove you out there
you did the challenge and then they just
drove you back yeah because you like
same night yep they said big fat loser
go home
and it's interesting because they've
done this I think like every year and
like it started with like they're just
like filming on dslrs yeah you're like
we should do this and then it became
like this was a whole entire budget and
was it they rented a mansion in the
Hills somewhere three hours away they
had like a camera crew they had like I
don't know it was wild but it's one of
those things where
I didn't really there's a cash prize at
the end I didn't really need the money
but Sarah Baska if you miss her yeah
she's great she's so funny and she's so
like just a lovely presence she was so
um in the red with her taxes okay
because you know influencer digital
money you don't know how to tax plan
yeah she was so in the red for taxes she
went on the show to win the cash prize
to pay her taxes and she has this like
I love Sarah hey I love you but she has
this emotional meltdown that's so funny
on the show on the show because she's
like she's like I [__] need this
money I need this money I'm gonna go to
jail everyone else was like yeah man I
guess I could put new rims on my G-Wagon
literally
it's so funny I make fun of her all the
time for it when it's really like not
funny at all and did she win
um I don't think so oh no but she got
them somehow she's fine she's actually
in prison right now yeah so that was
actually the last time I talked to her
yeah three years yeah yeah yeah so this
one's for you Sarah so we're actually
fine making fun of her because she's not
gonna see this they took her away yeah
yeah she for Life yeah yeah I've never
done any reality no never but
um never but
does that interest you I mean there are
there's so many they're not there's so
many types of reality shows supposed to
say you have seen every type of reality
show because you react to that that's
true yeah so like is there a certain I
would go on like wouldn't you go on like
you know I don't know like a game show
Family Feud
you wouldn't go on that
I would for sure go on Family Feud is
that where you like let's see the board
yeah a potato salad yeah show me foot
fetish yeah
um I would do that sure I would if it
was something that's a reality show
right or is that a game show it's a game
show I would do a game show I'd do a
game show I'll do a game show I used to
want to do like yeah I would do this one
I guess I am on a reality show they're
writing a movie oh my God there's gonna
be a real Bros the movie he's calling me
Conor's calling me
here we go
fibs
hello what are you doing
sitting at my house I just got out of
the meeting slay okay so question
yeah I'm at TMG I'm doing an episode
with Cody back into his [__] car
so like what hey POV you were me
what do you do
oh my God he's good it's fine he's
totally fine like you don't think he'll
like yell I feel so bad no I I promise
you like he seems like oh shoot but he
left like it's
so should I back into it like a little
more should I like crunch it really hard
on the driver's side so
okay I think I'm gonna call Ryan and
just start crying right now yeah I'm
like sitting in my car my Hey look
car
oh am I on the pot
[Laughter]
you were just content farmed thank you
for your service wow but by the way
thanks for being so nice thanks for
being like he'll be fine with it thanks
I was kind of worried you'd be like he's
such a he's such an [__] he's gonna
hit you in the face
you know he gets violent he gets violent
especially towards women you don't want
to see him mad
all right stop hitting on Cody thank you
for uh thank you for answering love you
thank you bye
you just got farmed you got farmed [__]
you got farmed flip that put it on Tick
Tock I felt bad I was like I had a pit
in my stomach
seriously
that is actually like I kind of felt
relieved too and he was like no he won't
be mad you're sitting next to me I'm
like okay good yeah yeah I got lost in
the role like damn you're right
oh what a good boss employee
relationship I'm not really his boss
sure you are yeah you're you're fired
Connor
you're done
yeah
actually we're inviting you to resign
requesting your immediate resignation
okay would you participate in a we just
did that one would you let Noel give you
a pedicure
interesting question yeah
the flip absolutely not I wouldn't touch
noelle's toes
we've never seen them no one has ever
seen them he refuses to show his feet to
us we did a whole episode about feet and
he refused it's true
so I don't know what they look like
maybe I'm sure I've seen them like on
the tour bus and [__] like that I think
I might have but hey you would have
remembered if you saw maybe yeah maybe
it'll give away his ethnicity
like his feet are like really like
whatever he is
yeah plays a lot of tennis
I wouldn't let no I'll touch my feet
I would let him do it for sure yeah I
mean doing a pedicure on my feet would
be like miserable so be kind of funny
sure you know yeah like don't you don't
forget the yeah yeah yeah get that
ingrown if you don't mind yeah exactly
yeah top 10 people I'd want to give me a
pedicure number four four Noel Miller
the last thing you want is someone's
foot fungus the last thing you want is
noelle's toes in your mouth yeah turns
out that might be what you get
would you take a bullet for Ryan no
hey really quick by the way is that
rhetorical or
think now we're doing funny questions
what think about it for a minute
would you take a bullet for Ryan just
let me think about that for a minute no
would you take a bullet for Cody
yeah and now you feel really [__] bad
don't you did I say no I meant yes oh my
God wait I was confused by the question
yeah yeah
for Ryan yeah yeah that's it from
[Laughter]
laughs